Speaker 1: Well, this really bums me out, but
podcaster Joe Rogan, on whose program I've
been a guest twice in the past, has unleashed
the juice love money stereotype trope. Call
it whatever you want, which is linked to so much
ugly anti-Semitism. Now I'm going to play the clip
and I'm going to talk about it. I do want to say
that I don't actually think that Joe Rogan has a
genuinely anti-Semitic bone or anti-Semitic ounce
of lean muscle mass in his body. I think that he
just doesn't understand why saying Jews love money
is different than the example he gives of Italians
love eating pizza. I just think he doesn't get
why. They are two different things. And it's a
very bad analogy. And as many of you know, I
don't know if Rogan's willing to have me back
on his program. You know, I've done some segments
since I was last on which were critical of things
he's said, but I think I've done them respectfully
and I would be glad to talk about any of my views
about his views any time. And I would love to
explain this to him as well. I have no idea.
But I don't think that this is
about Joe Rogan being an anti-Semite
just based on personally knowing him. Let's get
into the segment and hear how it all went down.
Speaker 2: The United States Senate sitting next
to Ilhan Omar, where she's she's apologizing for
talking about it's all about the Benjamins, which
is just about money she's talking about. Shouldn't
have apologized. I mean, some anti-Semitic
statement. I don't think that it's about
Benjamins or money. You know, the idea that Jewish
people are not into money is ridiculous. Listen,
it's like saying Italians aren't into
pizza. It's fine. I mean, listen, it's
stupid. I understand.
Speaker 1: Okay. So listen,
the analogy to Italians eating pizza couldn't be
more misleading and it couldn't be more wrong. And
there are a number of important points here. First
of all, analogizing to Republican to Republicans,
liking pizza, to Italians, liking pizza groups,
Jews liking money under a category of what we
might consider like positive things. And
this is the difficulty with some of these
anti-Semitic tropes that in a vacuum they sound
like positive things. You know, when people say
Jews do so well in the banking industry, you
might mean that in a totally benign way or not,
but it's connected to long standing conspiracies
of Jewish conspiracy to control certain industries
to their benefit and to the detriment of
others. And it's wrapped up in really, really
ugly stuff. So the analogy to it's just a good
thing liking money, liking pizza. It's just
it's a it's a totally fine and good thing that
that's one issue, which is it's connected to
all sorts of historical horrible stuff that
eating pizza by Italian people is not. Secondly,
it's not. Jews love money and Italians love
pizza, right? Everyone loves money. Jews are
the ones tagged with the stereotype that they are
so obsessed with money above and beyond everybody
else that they conspire to acquire it in a way
that's different than everybody else. I mean,
have you met black people who hate money? Have you
met white people who say, Oh, money? Throw it out,
put it in the trash, Burn it? Of course
not, because it's not about liking money.
Ascribing it to Jews is about something above and
beyond that. It's the conspiracy to obtain money,
including by immoral or illegal or deceptive
means, by controlling certain industries.
And it's different. It's unique in some way. And
it's linked to thousands of years of anti-Semitic
tropes, stereotypes and discrimination. Now, Rogan
might genuinely not know that, and so that's why
I'm being careful in saying I'm not alleging Joe
Rogan is an anti-Semite in saying these things.
I think he just doesn't understand or know the
reasons why. This is very different than Italians
like pizza. The last thing about this is the
analogy to pizza is also a terrible one because
Italians liking pizza isn't a collective action
linked to anti-Italian tropes and stereotypes
about Italian conspiracy to like pizza or pizza.
Like, it doesn't even make sense. As I say,
it doesn't make any sense. You're talking about
something that is individual. When the discussion
is about Jews liking money, it's no longer about
individuals, right? It's not about, oh, Jon
Stewart likes money. He loves money. It's a trait
that is ascribed to the group working together.
And that's where this entire, like, conspiracy
stuff comes from. So I. You know. It's really
important. A lot of times when people say this
stuff, they don't actually know or understand the
origins and they go, I don't know. It's just like
saying Jews like love. Money is like saying black
people are good at basketball is like saying
whatever, these sound like positive things,
but they're interlaced in that extra kabuki
with really ugly historical things stereotyping,
xenophobia, all sorts of stuff. And so it is
really easy sometimes for people to defend
this sort of thing and say liking money, it's not
even a bad thing, but it would be better if people
understood the history and really what it was that
that they were talking about. So again, I have no
personal beef with Rogan and whether or not I've
been blacklisted from his show, I genuinely have
no idea. But everything I've ever said on this
show about the things Joe has said I'd be willing
to talk about with him. I'm not hiding behind
a microphone or behind a screen or any of it.
I don't know if he has any interest in that, but
I am glad to any time on his program or on mine,